hello everyone I'm Alana welcome to my
channel and today I'm very excited to
catch up on a couple of new pieces of
Dead Space content that I've dropped we
have the official Gameplay trailer and
then I'm also I think going to check out
the engine room atmospheric walkthrough
which is what this is called which is an
art Deep dive
and an audio deep dive that they have
here as well but we'll start off with
just the trailer
I'm very excited about this
really looking forward to it also very
excited about Calista protocol but I
will take both like there's no too much
horror content for me there's no too
much Dead Space like content for me I'm
ready to go
um also yeah we're live on Twitch so
let's do it
this is the emergency maintenance
Isaac Clark yeah this audio is already
really good
Isaac yeah
handle it alone
makes the centrifuge look at that
lighting
well I mean the audio and Dead Space was
already brilliant
this is senior medical officer medical
is overwhelmed we 've helped
I will say like
some of it looks a bit Sharp
the Remake issue I'm not really sure
oh my God
such a good game dude it's such a good
game
I know they said uh in one of the blog
posts they were planning to expand
[Applause]
some of the zero g stuff I believe
foreign
it's all falling apart here
I can't believe what's happening
Nicole
so
this is actually
um
that's a really strange trailer
because
I so like I'm looking for stuff that I
know that they've spoken about which is
like one of the things that your bullets
are supposed to have more impact than
they did in the original Dead Space
which is really cool I know they updated
the sound design again the sound design
is already awesome changes to the
lighting I mean there are a lot of
changes across the board
but it's a weird trailer because I'm
mostly watching it from a nostalgic
perspective and I actually don't feel
like it sells the game
that well if you don't already like Dead
Space
strangely
um it's a massive upgrade graphically
like if we try and look at
some original Dead Space content there's
no doubt that that is just a huge jump
here
it looks so much better like the
lighting oh my God it just looks so so
much better
Isaac looks way better
yeah compare these two
clearly an enormous step up right
um the movement actually looks pretty
similar but like look at look at Isaac's
suit
and yeah everything's so dark because
all games did used to be all the games
are really bright like if you play uh
Master Chief collection and you jump
between the old and the new graphics
it's sometimes I would do that and I
would swap to the old Graphics just to
increase the brightness
um it's gonna be terrifying but yeah I
feel like something about this trailer
is
it's kind of strange it's just kind of a
strange trailer I feel like it's maybe
they don't really sell you on the story
of the direction it's more just like
sort of a montage of things
um which is cool for me because I like
looking at the things but like having
this interaction
it's one minute it's well edited
but like this just doesn't
foreign
I know it is cool maybe I'm wrong
it's a weird one though because like we
talk about you know there's so much talk
about remakes and remasters right now
and Dead Space actually is a game that I
fully think holds up I 100 think Dead
Space one still plays really really well
I'm excited about this more because it's
an excuse to replay this game than
because I think it needed it I'm excited
about it because I'm like hell yeah dude
I'll play dead space again
I've been meaning to do that anyway but
I fully don't think it it has actual
need for it at all even looking at uh
the way that video I closed it the way
that video looked
the gameplay still holds up it's still
super atmospheric it's still really
really really scary dead space holds up
um but I am
kind of weird trailer I'm super excited
to play it again and you know I do
definitely think that um based on past
Things based on industry Trends uh it
seems to be the case that
if you get a remake or a remaster it
tends to mean a sequel is on the way uh
we should expect a Dead Space 4
announcement at some point based on this
so let's watch the other two this one is
called the engine room atmospheric
walkthrough art Deep dive
so I'm expecting to see
some art updates here okay yeah it does
some fantastic lighting yeah absolutely
there we go yeah so just like we saw in
the concept it's dark uh it's very nasty
what's out there and we do that on
purpose to contribute to the fear of the
unknown right you don't know what's back
there or we're doing that on purpose but
then just there's just a little bit of
uh uh life in there just so that it's
not completely dead scene and then as we
look above us we see the the massive
engine I'm glad that I like again it
makes it so small and insignificant
remember every part of the game that
well because it's been long enough
like one of the best things in life is
getting a playthrough portal 2. Co-op a
second time or a third time because you
forget it earlier in gyms now you see it
here steam coming out of the pipes this
is kind of the same I don't remember it
that well the movie Pistons it gives
life you know it communicates that this
is an industrial thematic
I'll say sorry
I will not stop it it's horror
storytelling a little bit of the
narrative we have the various tools
every game's got you moving batteries
control kept that alive
gotta put batteries in things first
let's face this game about safety
okay so in this state uh now as pretty
as something as industrial assistant is
starting to power the wind so the engine
is slowly started to
rotate a little bit of light to it
um
you'll have to speak up we've booted up
an engine
they are really quiet compared to the
game let's follow the blood trail then
let's do that no it's always a good idea
so here we go this is the iconic poster
that we saw earlier you can see the
different treatments and the blood like
the one that is still wet
blood and I I've said this before but I
really do appreciate how candid
they're being about the development
more blood States
yeah Dead Space 2023
they've shared so much
turn it on let's turn it and we look up
above us and then we can see this
glorious you know VFX the engine's fully
operational it's open it's spinning at
full speed it's like a it's like a
beating heart
as the room has come to life and we have
completed transformation
it seems weird that right it doesn't
appear to be much light on
Isaac there
yeah
again just that just that great great
teamwork between the environment artists
and the story artist like I mean you can
really you you can guess what happened
there
and then we're back into darkness as we
make our way down and then we take one
last look
at the engine and in the smoke-filled
room
the light does look really good yeah
especially because yeah
terrify us with shadows so much more
it's gonna be it's gonna be real scary
and I can't wait uh okay let's watch
this is atmospheric walkthrough audio
Deep dive
I get a tiny bit louder because they
were very quiet
foreign
there some good raindrops
see some uh texture and still needs to
be done here again this is game in
development not representative of our
final release
it's okay about it I really really hope
that audiences um are receptive to it
and understand that they're seeing
something in development it doesn't hurt
sales that they've taken this approach
I just wish we had more transparency
across the board from
game devs
foreign
I think I remember this exact area
pretty well actually I think this is
do you want to see how the combat a
strange based on what they said
the lack of uis
CA though
foreign
drops dude this is gonna be dope on a
dual sense too
I'm excited I'm stoked to see it again I
felt like the trailer was like kind of
strange just I think it's just in the
way that it was paced Maybe
I'm not really sure um curious to see if
any of you have not played Dead Space
how you felt about it because obviously
I always try to like remove myself or
take one step back from this stuff and
so
I often fail I think I'm always like hmm
would I find this interesting if I
didn't already like dead space and that
I try and overthink it and it's like so
hard to guess
um I have no idea but
it does feel like a strange trailer the
OG trailer was like that as well I don't
remember it
but uh
yeah this um
I'm excited about it I'm very excited
for people who've never played Dead
Space to play dead space you are in for
a wild ride with what is still in my
opinion some of the best sound design in
any video game ever the first Dead Space
is bone chilling creepy if you want to
try dead space and you don't want a
scary and as scary experience try Dead
Space Three a lot of people don't like
it as much for that reason also it's a
lot more action oriented and there was
some really stupid crafting stuff
um but if you do want to try the
franchise and you don't want to go
straight into Dead Space which I think
is the scariest
three is the most successful and you can
play a co-op so that is pretty cool but
still I recommend you give it a try the
game rules the game rules it's very good